Welcome back everyone this will be my non-spoilery
spider-man no way home review i had a chance
to see the movie it is probably the biggest
spider-man movie that you will ever see so if
you're new to the channel we're doing a giveaway
for imax tickets for the movie all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite spider-man moment from any spider-man
movie in the comments below please don't post
big spoilers for people that do get to see
the movie early my full post credit scene video
for breakdown easter eggs videos will all start
posting later this week after the movie actually
comes out because there is a lot of stuff that we
have to talk about so run do not walk to go see
this movie you guys have no idea it completely
lives up to all the hype and normally you think
movies get overhyped you get kind of worried about
that people start to get kind of nervous when
movies come out like this it completely delivers
on everything it's not perfect by any means
in a lot of your enjoyment of the nostalgia
that they're going for in bringing back all these
tobey maguire andrew garfield spider-man villains
and all these easter eggs from all the spider-man
movies will just depend on how much you enjoyed
those older movies so for instance if you're an
older fan who has been to see all the spider-man
movies in the theater you might enjoy this movie
just a little bit more than like a really young
kid who's only known the tom hall and spider-man
but if you've been on the fence about tom
holland's portrayal as spider-man as this younger
high school kid spider-man in the mcu so far after
you see this movie tom holland will probably be
your favorite live-action spider-man i know it's
a tall order because tobey maguire's spider-man 2
is still probably one of the best superhero movies
of all time not just best spider-man movies of
all time but best superhero movies of all time
the animated spider-man into the spider-verse a
couple years ago kind of shook up those rankings
but the thing about spider-man no way home is that
it really is kind of like a live-action spider-man
into the spider-verse type of movie not in the
exact same way but you kind of understand they're
doing so many multiverse elements in the film that
it really is like a live-action spider-verse film
and the funny thing about that is that tom holland
said that kevin feige actually initially pitched
that idea as a joke like when they were coming
up with their early ideas for what spider-man
no way home could be they all said what about a
multiverse movie and then had a good laugh like
hahahaha but then kevin feige said but wait
what if we did do it as a multiverse movie
so we should really all thank kevin foggy for them
bringing back all these super deep cuts but the
basic premise of the movie is that spider-man has
been doxed by mysterio the whole world knows his
secret identity and he thinks it's going to ruin
his life it seems like it's going to ruin his life
so he goes to doctor strange to try and get him
to take it back to erase everyone's memories but
then winds up making things even worse leading
to the barriers between realities breaking down
between the multiverse breaking down in the tobey
maguire spider-man villains in the andrew garfield
spider-man villains like green goblin doctor
octopus electro sandman the lizard all coming
to the main mcu reality and him trying to fix
everything in a way that he feels comfortable
with that he feels is like the best way to do it
which puts him at odds with doctor strange who
is trying to find the simplest quickest way to
fix everything tom holland himself said it best
in a recent interview when they were doing fan
screenings of all the trailers a couple weeks ago
the spider-man often winds up on himself because
he will always put everyone else before himself
spider-man's biggest superpower is peter
parker and that's because of his humility
that's what sets him apart from the rest is that
he's always able he's unable to not do the right
thing and for me as an actor bringing that to
life has been so fun because it's sometimes
incredibly frustrating sometimes i i read these
scripts where i perform these scenes and i just
want peter parker to be selfish just one time
because he always he always puts everybody
else first and therefore he kind of he kind of
shits on himself and that is no different during
spider-man no way home it is a marvel movie
so yes it does set up a lot of future things
they do give you teasers and hints easter eggs for
things that are going to be happening in the next
couple of movies like doctor strange 2 multiverse
of madness the other marvel phase 4 movies there
are a lot of minor things that they could turn
into much bigger plot points in future spider-man
films when tom holland comes back but here's the
thing when people call it the biggest spider-man
movie of all time the director literally said when
they started releasing trailers a little while ago
that they're unofficially thinking of the movie
as spider-man end game so it kind of does for
the tom hall and spider-man mcu character the same
thing that avengers end game did for the avengers
it gives them a kind of ending but also a place
to pick up if they want to pick up again like
what happened to all the avengers characters
at the end of avengers end game they all kind
of went their separate ways we knew a couple
of them would come back we knew some of them
were probably not going to come back anytime soon
like they really gave iron man and captain america
endings if those actors wanted it but because
it's science fiction it's comic book movies
they could come back in ways if they wanted to
so the idea going into spider-man no way home
is that they wanted the movie to feel like an
ending of the homecoming trilogy like the end
of the idea of a high school spider-man dealing
with high school problems that's why little
while ago when they were talking about this new
spider-man trilogy that tom holland had supposedly
signed on for amy pascal was going on and on about
more and more spider-man movies with tom holland
he said that if they did come back and do more
movies the vibe would be completely different
the tone the story they would cover the look and
the feel of everything so once you see the movie
you kind of understand like avengers end game
meant to be a definitive end for this chapter in
the mcu spider-man endgame spider-man no way home
meant to be a definitive end for this chapter of
spider-man in the mcu and tom han totally brought
it if you were on the fence about his performance
in spider-man homecoming or even spider-man far
from home that's why i said you'll come out of
this movie and he'll probably be your new favorite
live-action spider-man the portrayal of spider-man
that you've always been hoping for in the mcu it
was no mistake when the russos called him the new
most important character in the mcu hands down
like we used to talk about robert danny jr's iron
man character being the new focal point of the
mcu like the most important character which is
why his arc and avengers end game hit so hard now
that's kind of spider-man spider-man is now the
new most important character in the mcu because
he was there for everything during the infinity
saga movies he was a kid watching all the avengers
come together he was there for avengers infinity
war avengers end game and he'll be there for
everything that's happening next so he is like the
ultimate mcu point of view character right now i
have a feeling that his lawyers are going to make
sure that he gets paid for those new spider-man
movies that he comes back for eventually
we are talking robert downey jr money and while
they were sort of using this as a giant bookend
to the homecoming trilogy it also kind of feels
like a sequel to the sony spider-man movies like
there's so much nostalgia so many easter eggs so
many things that they brought back from the tobey
maguire and andrew garfield spider-man movies that
at times spider-man no way home feels kind of like
spider-man 6 instead of like a sequel to the tom
holland mcu spider-man movies like you have the
three tobey maguire spider-man movies one two
and three then you have the two andrew garfield
amazing spider-man movies then you have this movie
like you could watch those first five than this
and it would feel like a complete arc so that's
like the new speed run version of spider-man like
if you're watching all the spider-man movies but
you want to do it in the quickest possible way
just watch spider-man one two you could
probably skip tobey maguire spider-man 3
watch andrew garfield's amazing spider-man 1 and
2 and then tom hall holland spider-man no way
home i myself was a big fan of all the nostalgia
all the easter eggs because i saw all those old
spider-man movies tobey maguire andrew garfield
movies in the theater so it was fun to see them
bring all these really cool things back and it
wasn't just the sinister six villain characters
themselves there were a lot of music easter eggs
a lot of visual easter eggs auditory easter eggs
the same way that the animated spider-man into the
spider-verse movie played four-dimensional chess
with the way they incorporated easter eggs like
you could watch that movie 10 times and still find
new easter eggs baked into everything the music
was amazing there was a leak i think a week ago
so some of you may have heard some of the music
tracks michael giaccino went hard he did not have
to go this hard it was amazing because the tobey
maguire spider-man movies and andrew garfield
spider-man movies are such a big part of this
obviously a lot of the music from their movies
are baked into and remixed with the tom holland
mcu movie music so there's a lot of really cool
remixed spider-man music tracks with easter eggs
for all the versions of spider-man talking about
the villains too green goblin definitely the main
villain of the film willem dafoe understood the
assignment when he came back for this he has
so much fun in this movie he is every bit the
green goblin you remember him to be from that
first tobey maguire spider-man movie the other
sinister six villains weren't quite as big of
characters as green goblin was but they all do get
really good arcs alfred molina's doctor octopus is
every bit as good as he was during spider-man 2.
jamie foxx's electro probably got the biggest
upgrade just because i feel like they kind of did
him a disservice during the amazing spider-man
2 so he actually feels legit during this movie
sandman and lizard were kind of lesser characters
but they still did get some good story during the
film but that's why you didn't see thomas hayden
church and reese ephons doing a lot of press with
the other three sinister six villains and even
though it is five villains they are really going
for sinister six vibes there's so many other
things that we could talk about but i don't
want to get into it until we're all talking about
spoilers after the movie comes out later this week
i will say that if you have a really strong
feeling about what's going on with this movie
you're at least partially right there were still
a lot of surprises a lot of things that i did not
expect but it is definitely my favorite marvel
movie of the year one of my favorite movies
overall of the year just in general of any kind
and it is an awesome way to close down the year so
that is why i say run do not walk to go see this
movie one to avoid any potential spoilers because
everybody on the planet is going to be talking
about this in a couple days but also because it's
just a really good movie yes there are multiple
post credits scenes do stay through the entire
credits you don't have a movie this big that
you've been hyping up for so long without having a
couple really really huge post credit scenes don't
worry i will do full videos for everything that's
going on during those after the movie comes out
on thursday and friday what'll happen is i might
do a full review video like my spoiler review on
thursday night and then start doing my post credit
scene videos on friday in my full breakdown videos
over the weekend but it'll take at least a week or
two to get through all the big spider-man things
that we need to talk about but don't worry i will
be doing a ton of spider-man videos between now
and the end of the year just to cover everything
once you do have a chance to see the movie just
post all your reactions in the comments below
my full hawkeye episode 5 video will post next
and then like i said all my spider-man no way
home full videos will start posting after that
everyone click here for all my spider-man no way
home videos and easter eggs and click here for
my hawkeye episode 5 yelena belova trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!